When some people think of anime, images of
Pokemon, Yu-Gi-Oh and other children’s shows
come to their brain, but there’s a whole
other world of smart, animated entertainment
that comes out of Japan.
And over the years, these movies and TV shows
have become primo inspirations for Hollywood
movies, whether they get credited or not.
So with that in mind, Screen Rant presents
10 Movies That STOLE From Anime Without Getting
Caught.
If you like it, remember to subscribe to the
Screen Rant channel and join the notification
squad!
The Matrix/Ghost in the Shell
The Matrix has a lot of iconic moments, but
the most famous is probably the digital “rain”
of green letters, an advanced coding system
which determines what goes on within The Matrix.
But guess what?
It didn’t originate from the Wachowskis.
Cyberspace is signified by a similar green
waterfall of digits in Mamoru Oshii’s Ghost
in the Shell, a hugely influential cyberpunk
anime from 1995.
The Wachowskis’ also borrowed the image
of someone being “plugged in” through
a port on the neck.
You can also see elements of Ghost in the
Shell in James Cameron’s Avatar, Steven
Spielberg’s Minority Report and Joss Whedon’s
Dollhouse.
It gets around!
Pacific Rim/Gigantor
Guillermo Del Toro’s Pacific Rim is an homage
to the Japanese kaiju and mecha animes of
the past, and there are a lot of series and
movies that inspired it.
But the film also takes directly from Gigantor,
an animated TV show from the 1950s that aired
pretty regularly on both Japanese and American
television.
The main giant robot, or “Jaeger,” of
the film, is called “Gipsy Danger,” and
its design is clearly derived from Gigantor,
the first giant robot of anime.
It makes sense within the context of the film,
as “Gipsy Danger” is an older, obsolete
Jaeger, which, ironically, is exactly what’s
needed to save the day.
Requiem for a Dream/Perfect Blue
Darren Aronofsky’s Requiem for a Dream was
praised for its innovative way of using montage
to demonstrate the effects of drug use.
The result is a visceral immersion into the
world of addiction, but little did people
know that Aronofsky was stealing techniques
from across the Pacific Ocean.
The famous “bathtub scene” - in which
an in-withdrawal Jennifer Connelly screams
into the water - was actually taken directly
from a similar scene in Perfect Blue, a 1997
anime thriller.
In fact, Aronofsky actually bought the rights
to Perfect Blue just so he could copy that
scene.
Avatar/Princess Mononoke
We already discussed the influence of Ghost
in the Shell on Avatar, but James Cameron
also stole some ideas from Hayao Miyazaki’s
classic Princess Mononoke, which is about
the spirits of a forest and their struggle
against the humans who want to exploit it
for resources.
Does that sound familiar?
Well, maybe because it’s just like the environmentalism
Avatar, which is about the Na’vi species
and their struggle against human colonizers
of Pandora.
Is it a coincidence?
We think not… as we’ve already established
that James Cameron is a fan of anime.
Scott Pilgrim vs. The World/Naruto
Edgar Wright’s Scott Pilgrim vs. The World
is based on a comic by Daniel Lee O’Malley,
and the inspiration of anime and manga on
that comic is obvious from O’Malley’s
drawing style.
But one anime stands out in particular.
In Naruto, the title character dreams of becoming
the most powerful ninja in his town, which
resembles the young Scott Pilgrim’s quest
to win the Battle of the Bands.
In addition, Pilgrim is clearly modeled on
Naruto, and even uses some of the catchphrases
that come from the Naruto TV show.
Looper/Akira
Akira is one of the most famous animes of
all time, and in 1989 it set the stage for
the Japanese animation invasion of the 1990s,
when American TV screens were filled with
imported Japanese series.
The darkly comic cyberpunk tale has inspired
everything from Christopher Nolan’s Inception
to the music video for Kanye West’s “Stronger.”
One movie that really takes from it, however,
is Rian Johnson’s Looper, about a time-traveling
hitman who gets sent back in time to be killed
by his own hand.
Johnson has called his movie a cross between
The Terminator and Akira, with Joseph Gordon-Levitt’s
character bearing a surprising resemblance
to the anime’s Tetsuo.
Her/Chobits
The premise of Her is that Joaquin’ Phoenix’s
lonely introvert falls in love with a Siri-like
operating system voiced by Scarlett Johansson
- or, as the jokes put it: he falls in love
with his phone.
But director Spike Jonze wasn’t the first
to latch on to this basic idea.
In the anime Chobits, which came out in 2002,
the main protagonist falls in love with an
android.
Both films make a point not to mock their
lonely main characters, and embrace the idea
that artificial technology can be an intellectual
match for humans.
Unlike some of the directors on this list,
however, Jonze has never spoken of his anime
influences.
Man of Steel/Birdy the Mighty
Zack Snyder is known for his super-stylish
action, and Man of Steel is no exception to
this.
We all know that the movie is based on DC’s
famous Superman comics, but Snyder also, obviously,
had a source of inspiration from across the
sea.
The main fight at the end of the film -- in
which Superman and General Zod battle it out
and destroy Metropolis in the process -- bears
a strong resemblance to the city-destroying
battles in an anime called Birdy the Mighty.
So if you’re wondering where Snyder’s
visual panache comes from… start checking
out some anime.
Transcendence/Serial Experiments Lain
The Johnny Depp-starring Transcendence was
a box office disappointment when it came out
in 2014, but you can’t say it wasn’t ambitious.
In the film, Depp plays a scientist whose
body dies, but he manages to stay alive in
computerized form, eventually growing in power.
It’s weird for a Hollywood film, maybe,
but the premise is pretty normal for an anime.
In fact, it was done 16 years earlier in Serial
Experiments Lain, in which a teenage girl
dies, but continues to contact her friends
digitally, and also begins to grow in power.
Inception/Paprika
And the grandaddy of all Hollywood anime-thefts:
Inception.
When this brain-teaser came out in 2010, it
wowed audiences with its idea of using technology
to invade people’s dreams.
The only problem?
That’s also the premise for Satoshi Kon’s
modern classic Paprika, which came out four
years before Nolan’s film.
In fact, the premise was so similar that a
planned American adaptation of the anime was
cancelled before production.
Most anime fans, however, would argue that
Kon’s film is the more imaginative and entertaining
one.
---
So how did you like our list?
Are there any other movies that stole ideas
from anime?
Subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one, and don’t forget to
join the notification squad so we can let
you know about more videos like this!